Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 44. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe. Und mancher wird es schon vermutet haben, da wir in der letzten Sendung ausführlich über die Mission BepiColombo gesprochen haben, die anstehende Raumflugmission zum Merkur. Schließen wir das ganze Thema hier auch rund ab und werfen einen Blick auf den Planeten selbst. Und dazu bin ich, keine große Überraschung, wieder in Berlin beim DLR, dem Institut für Planetenforschung gelandet, hier in Adlershof. Und um über den Merkur mehr zu erfahren, grüße ich Tilman. Tilman Spohn, hallo. Hallo. Du bist hier der Direktor des Instituts für Planetenforschung, was sich ja mit allen möglichen Planeten, die so zur Verfügung stehen, auseinandersetzt. Ich hatte ja schon mehrfach die Freude von hier zu berichten. Jetzt wollen wir uns halt mal auf den Merkur stürzen, obwohl der Termin so ein bisschen zur Unzeit ist, weil es ja auch die Woche ist, wo gerade die spektakuläre Mars-Landung des NASA Curiosity Rovers erfolgreich stattgefunden hat, vor zwei Tagen, um genau zu sein. Haben alle früh aufgestanden und haben wahrscheinlich alle aufstehen gehangen.
Alle haben alle geguckt. Ich war in meinem Büro und hatte das NASA TV an. Und konnte die Spannung sozusagen dann live mitkriegen und dann auch den Ausbruch des Jubels. Und der Grund, warum ich zu dieser doch relativ frühen Zeit in meinem Büro saß, war, weil dann gleich eine Rundfunkanstalt anrief und wollte das dann kommentiert haben. Ich hab jetzt schon wieder vergessen, wer das war. Es gab dann nachher noch ein paar andere. Also das heißt, wir haben dann unmittelbar dann... Radio Prem, das Radio Prem, haben dann darüber gesprochen. Ja, das ist eine ganz tolle Geschichte. Vor allen Dingen halt auch die Landetechnik, die man da angewendet hat, die ja, wenn man sich das so ansieht, in dem Movie. Das sieht ja schon aus wie Science-Fiction. Also wenn der Sky-Crane dann da über der Oberfläche schwebt und dann den Rover runterlässt und dann wieder wegfliegt, dann hat man das Gefühl, zumindest in dem Film, der da zu sehen ist, dass der dann sozusagen nach Hause fliegt. Er fliegt nicht nach Hause, sondern er fliegt ein Stückchen weiter und fällt dann runter, aber der sieht mehr dann nicht. Ich kann übrigens sagen, an der Stelle, das ist mir schon ein Anliegen, es gibt ja in den Medien diesen schönen Film, wo man dann sieht, wie der da runterkommt. Und man sieht also auch den Mars, die Mars-Landschaft, den Gate Crater und wie der immer näherkommt. Diese Bilder sind von uns hier gerechnet. Das sind Bilder von der HRSC, der hochauflösenden Stereokamera, die auf der Mars Express-Mission fliegt. Immer noch. Seit 2003 ist die Mission gestartet, fliegt also immer noch. Und die Kollegen hier haben dann diese Daten genommen. Sie haben also diese Szenen gerechnet und diesen Film da zusammengestellt. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz wunderbarer Film.
Ich fand, was ich noch bemerkenswert fand, da ist ja schon angesprochen, diese Emotionalität dieses Moments. Ich hab mir auch so dieses Video, glaube ich, jetzt vier, fünf Mal angeschaut, wie dieses Team dort saß und irgendwie auf das Eintreffen dieser Daten wartete. Ich denke, das ging nicht nur diesem Team so, sondern das ging eigentlich auch der gesamten Forschergemeinde weltweit so.
Das ist sicherlich richtig. Ich muss auch sagen, mit Abstufung wahrscheinlich. Ich kann mir vorstellen, die waren nervöser, als ich das persönlich jetzt so weit weg gewesen bin. Das muss man schon zugeben, denn wenn man da Jahre und Jahrzehnte seines Lebens investiert hat und jetzt kommt es also auf diesen Augenblick an, dass der da landet und dann auch sicher runterkommt, wenn man bedenkt, wie riskant Landungen auf dem Mars eigentlich sind und wie riskant es ist, so etwas zum ersten Mal auszuprobieren. Da ist dann sicherlich das Herz ganz weit oben geklopft und da war man aufgeregt. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass bei uns die Aufregung groß sein wird, wenn 2014 dann Rosetta, der Rosetta Lander, dann auf dem Churyumov-Cherasimenko landen wird. Dann sind wir betroffen und dann werden wir wahrscheinlich da sitzen und es wird also große Herzklopfen geben und wir werden nervös sein und werden dann hoffen, dass der dann gut runterkommt, obwohl das natürlich ganz andere Dinge sind. Also es ist ja mehr so ein Andocken an den Kometen, als das, was die jetzt gemacht haben, also ein Landung auf dem Planeten Mars. Aber es ist genauso oder ähnlich oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr Terra-Incognita, die wir da haben. Wir wissen nicht, wie der Komet die Oberfläche beschaffen ist. Wir wissen nicht, was uns da genau erwartet, während man dann doch die Oberfläche auf dem Mars dann sehr viel genau erkannte. Andererseits haben wir jetzt nicht dieses Risiko, wie da jetzt mit der neuen Wandeltechnologie und der Gravitationskraft natürlich, die auf dem Mars viel stärker ist und die dann gefährlich ist. Also es gibt hier Risiken und da Risiken. Und wir werden dann also an der Stelle, werden wir dann nervös sein und werden hoffen, dass das alles gut geht.
Spannend wird sicherlich dann auch, wenn BepiColombo dann den Merkur erreicht. Zu den erwähnten Missionen kann ich auch gleich nochmal hier ins Raumzeitprogramm zurückverweisen über Giotto und dann eben auch die Nachfolgemission Rosetta. Haben wir hier in Ausgabe 20 gesprochen mit Gerhard Schwem. Und auch Mars Express kam schon mal zur Sprache, nämlich in der Sendung um Missionsplanung als Beispiel für wie man denn solche komplexen Bahnen berechnet. Das war natürlich jetzt auch bei der BepiColombo-Sendung ein wichtiges Thema. Aber ich kann auch schon vorwegnehmen, Mars Express und auch der Mars wird hier noch ein Thema sein. Und dann werden wir sicherlich auch schon so die ersten Ergebnisse von dem Mars Space Laboratory, so sie dann eben vorliegen, schon ein bisschen wälzen können. Ja, aber eigentlich wollten wir ja hier, und das machen wir jetzt auch, über den Merkur sprechen, der kleine Planet so schön nah dran an der Sonne, der so ein bisschen, ja weiß ich nicht, übertreibe ich jetzt so eine Außenseiterrolle spielt, weil ja noch nicht so viele Missionen dorthin auch gelangt sind, obwohl er ja vergleichsweise nah ist?
Das ist korrekt. Es sind zunächst mal einfach weniger Missionen dahin gekommen. Das liegt einfach daran, dass es technisch eine sehr große Herausforderung ist, zu dem Merkur zu fliegen. Zumindest aus zwei Gründen. Und zunächst mal ist es einfach die thermische Belastung dort, die sehr groß ist, die dann auch letztlich dazu führte, dass es die Verzögerung BepiColombo gegeben hat, die wir ja inzwischen haben. Wir starten hier jetzt doch deutlich später, als wir ursprünglich mal starten wollen. Aber ich nehme an, das habt ihr in der letzten Sendung dann diskutiert. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass es schwierig ist, in die Umlaufbahn sich einzuschießen. Ich stelle mir das immer so vor und erkläre das auch den Studenten. Wir haben also einen sehr großen Potenzial-Topf, in dem die Sonne sitzt. Und da in dieser Wand dieses Potenzial-Tops ist so eine kleine Delle drin. Das ist sozusagen das Potenzialfeld des Merkurs, mit dem sich der Sonne überlagert. Und da muss ich jetzt rein. Und da muss ich genau so da rein, dass ich dann von dieser kleinen Vertiefung da aufgefangen werde. Also es gibt ja, in Museen hat man ja oft diese Geschichten, wo man diesen Potenzial-Topf dargestellt hat, als Fläche, die also da nach innen geht. Man kann da so eine Kugel reinrollen lassen. Jetzt stellt man sich vor, ich hätte jetzt also in dieser Fläche da so eine kleine Delle drin und müsste jetzt da reinzielen. Und müsste denn da reinkommen können, dann hat man vielleicht so eine gewisse Vorstellung, wie schwierig es ist, dass also einfach zu Merkur zu fliegen. Und es hat ja eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis man das im Griff hat. BepiColombo, Giuseppe Colombo, war ja unter anderem der, der als Pionier tätig war und gezeigt hat, wie man dann zu Merkur kommt. Zusätzlich zu der Erklärung, die er geliefert hat für die Spin Orbit, also zu den umlaufbaren Rotationsperiodenkopplungen, die der Merkur ja aufweist. Insofern ist die Mission BepiColombo sicherlich zu Recht in seinem Namen benannt, obwohl viele es lieber gesehen hätte, wenn sie Giuseppe Colombo gehiesen hätte und nicht Bepi, weil das haben manche so als ein bisschen demonitiv empfunden.
Aber es war sein Spitzname, oder?
Es war sein Spitzname, ja. Insofern ist es korrekt. Und der Vorschlag kam aus Italien, also was wollen wir mehr können?
Bevor wir uns jetzt noch mal konkreter um den Merkur kümmern, würde mich natürlich interessieren, wieso dein Weg zum DLR gewesen ist. Zum Thema Planetenforschung.
Also mir war es jetzt nicht unbedingt so sehr in die Wiege gelegt, wie manchen anderen, der schon als Kind zu den Sternen geguckt hat und sagt, da würde ich unbedingt auf dem Mond rumlaufen.
Mond sei du verpasst.
Nein, die hab ich sogar gesehen. Zu der Zeit war ich, ich glaub, 19, ja 19. Und ich muss allerdings sagen, zu der Zeit hab ich auch andere Interessen gehabt, als jetzt die Mondlandung zu gucken. Aber wir haben die damals natürlich gesehen, wir haben gesehen, wie der Armstrong da runtergekommen ist und gesagt hat, das ist ein großer Schritt, ein kleiner Schritt für einen Menschen, aber ein großer Schritt für die Menschheit. Und ich war zu der Zeit eigentlich mehr auch so an Theater und künstlerischen Dingen interessiert und hab dann angelassen am Abitur, mich um die Naturwissenschaften oder für die Naturwissenschaften näher interessiert, dann Physik studiert und später Geophysik, also Physik in Mainz und Darmstadt, später Geophysik in Frankfurt und hab auch als Geophysiker promoviert, diplomiert und promoviert, zunächst als Seismologe, also Erdbebenforschung, dann später als Geodynamiker, der sich um die Thermodynamik des Erdinnen kümmert. Das ist auch was ich heute mehr oder weniger noch tue. Und bin dann als Postdoc zur UCLA, also zur Universität California in Los Angeles gegangen, zu meinem Kollegen Jerry Schubert, der so ein bisschen wie ich das heute auch mache, eigentlich so einerseits sich um die Geophysik kümmert, ich bin ja von Hause als Geophysiker, aber andererseits auch um die Geophysik der Planeten. Also versucht, den Blick sozusagen weiterzufassen über die Erde hinaus zu den anderen Körpern und von dem habe ich eine Menge gelernt und habe damals sozusagen mein Aha-Erlebnis gehabt, als ich auf der Jahrestagung der AGU, der American Geophysical Union, die Bilder des Voyager-Vorbeiflugs am Saturn gesehen habe. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass ich damals zurückgekommen bin dann nach Los Angeles, die Tango ist in San Francisco, und habe Jerry dann erzählt, begeistert, dass ich diese Bilder gesehen habe von dem Verbeiflug am Jupiter.
Oh, na gut, und dann haben wir zusammen...
Ja, der war groß, es gab eine Menge Monde. Dann haben wir zusammen das eine oder andere Paper über Mars gemacht und auch über terrestrische Planeten, also versucht, die magnetischen Eigenschaften der terrestrischen Planeten zu verstehen. Mit dem Kollegen Dave Stevenson, der ja als Nestor für die theoretische Planetenforschung gelten darf, oder zumindest einer der wichtigen Leute da ist. Und so bin ich dann eigentlich zur Planetenforschung gekommen. Und dann hatte ich das Glück, nach Münster berufen zu werden, bald darauf auf eine Professur für Planetengeologie, hieß das damals, obwohl ich eigentlich bei Planetenphysik betrieben hab und eigentlich gar nicht von mir behaupten darf, ein Geologe im engeren Sinne zu sein. Aber im weiteren Sinne sind wir ja alle Geologen. Und war dann dort eine ganze Reihe von Jahren, hab also geholfen, das Institut für Planetologie in Münster aufzubauen und bin dann halt im Jahre 2000 und vier ist das gewesen. 2003 ging es eigentlich schon los, aber 2004 letztlich dann zum DLR gekommen. Hab meine Professur in Münster behalten, sodass ich dort auch gelegentlich leere. Und bin seitdem halt hier Institutsleiter und versuche, das Institut voran zu bringen oder auf den Weg zu halten, wie man es immer nennen möchte.
Ja, das Institut scheint ja ganz gut beschäftigt zu sein im Bereich der Planetenforschung. Das ist ja hier in den früheren Gesprächen auch schon deutlich mitgekommen. Bezugnehmend auf BepiColombo, wie sind da so die Verbindungen von dem Institut zu der Mission?
Ja, als nächstes will ich mal sagen, dass das Institut ist, heute war es eigentlich auch immer sehr breit aufgestellt. Und wir beteiligen uns an Weltraummissionen, soweit wir das können. Sodass das in unserer Kompetenz liegt. Also die spezifische Mission in unserer Kompetenz liegt. Und das ist also bei BepiColombo sicherlich der Fall. Die Ausschreibung für die Instrumente auf der Mission kam damals, kurz nachdem ich nach Berlin gekommen war. Und ich war damals in dem Science-Team, was geholfen hat, die Mission zu definieren. Und ich hatte damals das Interesse gehabt oder darauf hingewiesen, dass neben der Schwerefeldmessung, die dort gemacht werden sollte, eigentlich auch die Topographie vermessen werden sollte. Und habe deshalb gesagt, wir müssen unbedingt in diese Pilot dann ein Laser-Altimeter mit hineinbringen, was dann für die Auswahl der Mission, das ist ja ein Wettbewerb immer, die Vorstellung dann noch so ganz am Ende, so eben noch so reingerutscht ist. Und wir haben damals gesagt, das soll also zwei Kilo haben und ein kleines Instrument. Clementine leider war sozusagen das Vorbild. Heute ist das Laser-Altimeter das schwerste Instrument auf der BepiColombo-Mission. Das hat sich also dann sehr weit entwickelt. Wir haben das damals gar nicht so richtig einschätzen können, wie so ein Laser-Altimeter denn da genau funktionieren würde. Wir wussten ja, wir sollten so was da drauf haben. Und als ich dann beim DLR gelandet war, habe ich dann halt den Kollegen hier vorgeschlagen, ob wir nicht, nachdem sie ja bewiesen haben, schon seit vielen langen Jahren, dass sie eine Kameratechnologie sehr gut beherrschen, ob man nicht als Ergänzung zunächst mal auch in die Lasertechnologie einsteigen wollen. Und wir haben dann, nach einigem Hin und Her, uns zusammengetan mit der Universität Bern, mit dem Physikalischen Institut dort im Wesentlichen, mit dem Max-Planck-Institut für Sonnensystemforschung in Kattenburg-Lindau und mit der Universität von Granada und haben dann entwickelt seitdem also dieses Laser-Altimeter für BepiColombo mit dem Namen Bela, also BepiColombo Laser-Altimeter. Sollte aber nicht vergessen, dass wir ein zweites Instrument auf der Mission haben, das ist das Instrument Mertes, das ist Mercury Thermal Infrared Spectrometer, wobei es hier so ist, dass der Kollege Hiesinger von der Universität Münster, der sozusagen auf meine Professur dort nachgefolgt ist, der Principal Investigator ist, während wir hier in Berlin das Instrument im Wesentlichen bauen und einen Co-Principal Investigator, den Kollegen Helbert, hier am Institut haben. Das heißt also, hier sind wir mehr die technische Seite, aber auch die wissenschaftlich interpretierende Seite, während die Instrumentenführung dann in Münster liegt. Bei dem Laser-Altimeter ist es so, dass der Kollege Nicholas Thomas von der Universität Bern und ich uns in dieser Rolle des Lids teilen. Das haben wir so verabredet, dass er den Lid hat. Wir bauen den Lid-Lid und ich habe dann den Lid-Lid, nachdem wir dann, wenn wir da sind, in die Operationsphase reingehen. So haben wir uns ein bisschen aufgeteilt, weil die ESA immer einen Ansprechpartner haben will. Aber im Prinzip, und das geht auch sehr gut, und ich kann auch sagen, das ist eigentlich ein prima Modell, kann es sein, muss nicht sein, kann es sein, dass man auch so ein Instrument mal zu zweit anführt. Sonst ist es ja gewöhnlich, so ist das immer einer, der ein Lid ist. Das funktioniert hier gut.
Jetzt mal ein ganz interessanter Blick auf so eine Mission. Bei BepiColombo, als ich mit Elsa Moutagnon gesprochen habe, deren Aufgabe ist natürlich vor allem die Flugleitung, da sieht man, dass das Ding natürlich so als Ganz ist. Man nimmt das ja auch immer so als Ganz, als es war. Tatsächlich entsteht aber die eigentliche Qualität der Mission natürlich dann letztlich durch die operativen Instrumente, die da drauf sind und hinter jedem Instrument steckt dann, darum merkt man jetzt auch schon bei der Beschreibung auch nur mal der personellen Zusammenstellung von einem oder zweien, eine komplexe Struktur von wissenschaftlichen Organisationen und Universitäten und natürlich den Wissenschaftlern selber, die dann eben sowohl bei der Entwicklung als natürlich auch bei der Auswertung beteiligt sind.
Das ist vollkommen richtig. Das ist schon komplex. Wenn man das dann runter bricht und guckt dann in die einzelnen Instrumente rein, dann sind das in der Regel relativ große Teams. Das kann, das variiert auch. Es gibt Instrumente, die haben relativ kleine Teams. Es gibt andere, die haben Teams von 100 Wissenschaftlern, die daran beteiligt sind, die dann auch alle ihre Rollen in dem Team haben, dann in dem Bau des Instruments. Das ist die eine Seite. Man muss Leute haben, die in der Lage sind, also erstens mal so ein Instrument zu designen, also rauszukriegen, wie mache ich das denn, die technischen Lösungen zu finden für die Herausforderungen, die da auf einem zu kommen. Wie auch dann nachher, wie interpretiert man die Daten? Was kann man denn dann an Daten dort herausholen, die dann wiederum von Wissenschaftlern, die mehr auf der interpretierenden Seite sind, dann umgesetzt werden können in Modelle der Entwicklung des Merkurs oder sagen wir mal für das Laser-Altimeter zunächst mal einfach der Tropographie und der Marphologie des Planeten.
Sind denn letztendlich dieselben Wissenschaftler, die die Anforderungen definieren für diese Geräte, die es dann letzten Endes auch auswerten?
Das ist in der Regel so, wobei man allerdings bedenken muss, dass bei manchen Missionen, da ist BepiColombo gerade so in Grenzfall so ein bisschen. Wenn ich zum Mars fliege, dann habe ich damit zu rechnen, dass ich in knapp einem Jahr dort bin. Dann muss natürlich bedacht werden, dass so ein Instrument beantragt, zunächst mal vorgeschlagen, die Mission entwickelt werden muss. Das kann zehn Jahre dauern. Wenn ich aber dann Missionen habe, wie BepiColombo, oder noch extremer Rosetta oder noch extremer eine Mission zum Uranus, dann muss ich auch noch mit langen Zeiten rechnen, die wir fliegen. Oder Jus, also zum Jupiter-System, wo sieben Jahre sind. Bei BepiColombo sind es sechs Jahre. Zu dieser Entwicklungszeit kommt dann auch noch die Flugzeit dazu. Und dann nachher die Auswertezeit, dass man dann schon einige Jahrzehnte im Blick haben muss. Und da kann es durchaus sein, dass A, die Mission definiert, aber bald zu einem Zeitpunkt letztendlich der Datenauswert und dann entweder nicht mehr im Dienst ist oder ansonsten nicht mehr verfügbar ist, während B dann sozusagen herangewachsen ist und dann die Auswertung übernimmt. Also bei mir wird es so sein, ich werde dann zu einem Zeitpunkt, bei dem BepiColombo ankommt, eigentlich formal nicht mehr im Dienst sein. Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das denn dann machen.
Aber wenn es nicht dieselben Leute sind, dann sind es sozusagen dieselben Abteilungen. Also das, was die Leute, die letztlich auswerten, sind auch die, die die Anforderungen definieren?
Ja, das ist so. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen vermessen, aber in gewisser Weise haben wir es hier zu tun auch mit so einer Art generationenübergreifenden Dingen. Das ist jetzt nicht so extrem wie der Kölner Dom, aber man gibt schon weiter. Als Planetenforscher muss ich schon sagen, dass ich auch für die Dinge arbeite, die dann die, die nach mir kommen, dann irgendwie dann auswerten werden. Bei BepiColombo ist es ganz klar so, der Kollege Andrej Balog, damals vom Imperial College in London, der heute schon seit vielen Jahren emeritiert ist, der ist derjenige gewesen, der damals, ich muss mich noch mal erinnern, wann das gewesen war, Anfang 2000, der damals sozusagen das Master meint und derjenige gewesen ist, der diese Mission vorangetrieben hat. Und wenn ich jetzt noch mal bedenke, dass es noch mal zwei, drei Jahre dauern wird, bis wir den Start tatsächlich haben und dann noch mal sechs Jahre, bis wir dort ankommen, dann kann ich mir natürlich ausdenken, dass der Kollege Bellock dann doch hauptsächlich seine Aktivität, das hat er auch schon, abgegeben hat an andere. Und so arbeiten wir halt eben auch über Generation hinweg und geben die Dinge dann auch weiter. Und das ist auch ein Problem, was man als Institutsleiter hier im Institut dann im Auge beharren muss. Also ich muss als Institutleiter heute darüber nachdenken, wer denn die langfristig angelegten Projekte dieses Instituts dann in einer Zukunft, in der ich gar nicht mehr hier sein werde, dann übernehmen wird. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel über Jus nachdenken, also die Jupiter-Mission, die ja jetzt nun gerade beschlossen ist, dann muss ich mir heute Gedanken darüber machen, wie definieren wir heute sozusagen die wissenschaftlichen Anforderungen und wie kann ich die Kontinuität wahren, damit das dann in 22, also in 10, 15 Jahren von heute dann auch dann hier umgesetzt werden kann. Aber wir gehen davon aus, dass dieses Institut dann immer noch sozusagen führen in der Definition des Laser-Altimeters auf dieser Mission. Also das ist jetzt das nächste Laser-Altimeter, was wir bauen wollen. Heißt dann nicht mehr BELAS, sondern GALA, Ganymede-Laser-Altimeter, dass wir das aus diesem Institut aus machen werden.
Ganymede, der Mond.
Der Ganymede ist der Mond des Jupiters, der das Hauptziel der JUICE-Mission ist. Also JUICE heißt Jupiter Icy Moon Explorer und das Hauptziel, Hauptobjekt der Begierde sozusagen in dem Jupitersystem ist der Mond Ganymede und neben Europa, aber Ganymede ist das Hauptziel.
So, jetzt haben wir viel über andere Planeten schon gesprochen. Jetzt ist klar, BepiColombo wird bald, also bald in diesen Dimensionen, über die wir eben gesprochen haben, also irgendwann dann starten. So eine Mission hat natürlich auch ein wissenschaftliches Interesse und das basiert natürlich vor allem erst mal darauf, was man eigentlich bisher weiß. Wie ist denn nun so das Bild, was man von dem Merkur bisher hat gewinnen können mit den zwei bisher gestarteten Missionen? Die eine ist ja noch im Betrieb, Messenger. Wie kam die Menschheit überhaupt zum Merkur? Der ist ja auch sehr schwer zu erkennen. Seit wann weiß man denn eigentlich, dass es den gibt?
Nach meinem Kenntnisstand darf davon ausgehen, der ist in der Antike schon bekannt gewesen. Der Götterbode Hermes ist ja die mythologische Repräsentation des Planeten, der in unserem Breiten schwer zu beobachten ist als Amateurastronom, weil er so tief am Himmel steht. Das ist anders in südlicheren Gebieten. Aber was interessiert Merkur? Und wie konnte man der ESA verkaufen, dass man eine doch recht teure Mission, eine Cornerstone-Mission, also der planetare Cornerstone, in den damaligen Zeiten haben die Missionen sogar, die großen Missionen sogar heißen, denn zu Merkur machen sollte. Und was man da an der Stelle dann immer gesagt hat und auch heute noch sagt, ist, dass der Merkur in gewisser Weise einen Schlüssel zum Verständnis der frühen Entwicklung, der Entstehung der frühen Entwicklung des Sonnensystems beinhaltet. Merkur ist der sonnennächste Planet. Und das zeichnet ihn schon mal aus. Das heißt also, wenn ich verstehe, wie der Merkur entstanden ist, dann verstehe ich oder habe ich Zugang zu dem Verständnis des Körpers, der sozusagen an der Grenze von dem Stern, der sich da bildet, zu dem ersten Planeten, der sich im Abstand von dem Stern dann gebildet hat, passiert. Aber andererseits weiß man vom Merkur schon, also seit dem Vorbeiflug durch die beiden Marinersonden, dass der Planet ungewöhnliche Eigenschaften hat, die also nicht so ganz in unsere Statistik reinpassen. Er ist auf der einen Seite von seinem Aussehen her, was wir also durch Messenger eigentlich recht gut kennen, aber bis Messenger hatten wir einfach nur 40 Prozent der Oberfläche, die tatsächlich abgebildet worden ist, von den beiden Vorbeiflügen, dass die Oberfläche etwa aussieht, wie die Oberfläche des Mondes, also sehr stark zerkratert. Das heißt, ich darf sagen, diese Oberfläche ist alt und ist also nicht zum Beispiel wie die Oberfläche der Venus oder insbesondere der Erde durch interne Aktivität überprägt worden und im Laufe der Zeit verändert worden. Oder wie die Oberfläche des Jupiter-Monds Europa oder zum Teil die Oberfläche des Jupiter-Monds Ganymede, wo also interne endogene Prozesse dann dazu führen, dass die Spuren, die Narben, die entstanden sind in dem Bombardement, in der Spätfolge der Bildung der Planeten dann auf der Oberfläche hinterlassen worden sind. Also, so sieht der Merkur von außen aus, ganz ehrlich wie der Mond. Das heißt, eine alte Oberfläche, auch ein alter Körper. Auf der anderen Seite...
Also der ist auch hart und bewegt sich nichts.
Bewegt sich erstmal nicht viel. Gut, und dann auf der anderen Seite ist er aber recht schwer. Das heißt, er hat eine relativ hohe Dichte. Und die Dichte, also wenn man die jetzt nun vergleicht mit der Dichte der Erde, dann liegt die ein bisschen darunter. Also 5500 Kilogramm pro Kubikmeter, oder 5,5 Gramm pro Zentimeter ist die Dichte der Erde im Mittel. Und die von Merkur ist ein bisschen kleiner. Was man zunächst sagen könnte, naja, okay, also ist ein erdähnlicher Planet, sollte auch die ähnliche Dichte haben. Nur, die Erde ist dreimal so groß, und im Inneren der Erde ist das Material komprimiert. Das heißt also, die Dichte ist durch Kompression erhöht. Wenn ich diese Kompression rausrechne, dann bekomme ich eine Dichte, die liegt eher bei 4 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter, und nicht bei 5,5. Und bei Merkur ist es so, wenn ich da die Kompression rausrechne, lande ich immer noch.
Gramm oder Kilogramm, was war das jetzt?
Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter. Der Physiker nimmt normalerweise Kilogramm pro Kubikzentimeter, muss damit Tausende operieren. Im Kolokwial, also im Gespräch, nehmen wir es einfach als Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter. Das heißt, der Merkur hat eine Zusammensetzung, die deutlich schwerer ist als die Zusammensetzung der Erde. Das ist also die Folge, die man einfach daraus zieht, wenn man lediglich die Masse und die Größe des Planeten betrachtet. Also ganz fundamentale Parameter. Ich gucke mir nur das an. Und das bedeutet halt, dass seine chemische Zusammensetzung, seine grobe chemische Zusammensetzung schon, deutlich anders sein muss als die der Erde. Gut. Was kommt in Frage? Wir stellen uns ja die Planeten ganz einfach, wenn wir eine ganz einfache Suppenküche von Planeten machen, dann stellen wir uns vor, dass die aus drei Komponenten bestehen können. Da ist einmal Wasserstoff Helium. Das ist die sogenannte Gaskomponente, aus der besteht hauptsächlich der Jupiter und der Saturn. Dann haben wir die sogenannte Eiskomponente. Das ist das Wasser, Methan und Ammoniak. Aus dem bestehen zu einem gut Teil die Eismonde und auch Uranus und Neptun haben sehr viel davon. Und die Gesteinseisen-Komponente, aus denen bestehen die terrestrischen Planeten im Wesentlichen. Und in dieser Gesteinseisen-Komponente gibt es jetzt noch eine Gleichgewicht zwischen Gestein und Eisen. Das ist nur bei der Erde so, dass das Eisen etwa ein Viertel des Anteils des Planeten macht. Aber Merkur muss es deutlich mehr sein. Das heißt, er hat also einen Eisenkern, davon dürfen wir auch rausgehen, dass er sich gebildet hat, dass er differenziert ist, der wesentlich größer ist als der Eisenkern der Erde. Wenn wir den Eisenkern der Erde betrachten, dann sagen wir in der Regen, was wissen wir? Durch seismische Experimente ist das gut bekannt. Der Radius des Eisenkerns der Erde ist etwa halb der halbe Planetenradius. Wenn ich da von innen rausgehe, nach der Hälfte, komme ich sozusagen an den Grant des Eisenkerns. Bei Merkur muss es in der Gegend von 80 Prozent liegen. Also 80 Prozent des Planetenradius entspricht dem Kernradius, dem Eisenkernradius des Merkur. Da kommt natürlich jetzt sofort die Frage, wieso hat der so viel Eisen? Das ist also eine der großen Fragen, die wir da haben. Und die Frage zielt dann ab auf die Entstehung. Wie kann es sein, dass der entstanden ist, sodass er eben so viel Eisen abkriegt?
Ist es denn nicht ohnehin so, dass jetzt die schweren Dinge in unserem Sonnensystem sich eher näher zur Sonne hin bewegen, so wie ja generell die Gasplaneten eben weit draußen sind? Die Steinplaneten sind halt die vier Inneren. Da ist es ja jetzt erstmal nicht so überraschend, dass man sagt, ja okay, und umso näher man jetzt rankommt, da wird es dann auch immer schwerer.
Ja, das ist also vollkommen richtig. Man muss noch dazusagen, also ich wollte das einfach noch ergänzen, wenn man die anderen drei erdähnlichen Planeten betrachtet, also Venus und Mars, dort hat man ähnliche Verhältnisse wie bei der Erde. Also auch dort ist der Anteil des Eisens an der Zusammensetzung des Planeten ganz ähnlich wie in der Erde. Merkur ist die Ausnahme.
Okay, also der sticht dann nochmal deutlich heraus.
Der sticht dann nochmal deutlich heraus. Und was ich sage, ist vollkommen richtig. Also man hat die erste Erklärung, die frühe Erklärung, dafür war gewesen, na ja, wenn wir also so einen Nebel haben, aus dem die Planeten sich bilden, dann hat man einen Temperaturgradienten in diesem Nebel. In diesem Temperaturgradienten werden also die weniger flüchtigen Bestandteile kondensiert bei den hohen Temperaturen. Und deshalb ist es vollkommen natürlich, dass also dort, wo es heiß ist, hauptsächlich die Elemente zu finden sind, die auch die hohen Kondensationstemperaturen haben. Aus dem Grunde ist es gut verständlich, dass also der Merkur da innen sich bildet und die anderen dann weiter draußen eben höhere Anteile an flüchtigen Bestandteilen haben. Und das zieht sich hier auch als generelles Bild zu unserem System. Dieses Bild ist gestört worden, als man anfing von den Gaskondensationsmodellen à la Zafronov, der also das Pionier der Entstehungsmodelle, der im Prinzip eine Theorie entwickelt hat, die an diese Laplace-Kanttheorie entwickelt. Dass die Sonne also eine Wolke um sich herum hat, also ich denke mal als Wolke entstanden ist, durch eine Rotationsinstabilität bildet sich die Sonne und darum dann halt eine Scheibe und in der Scheibe bilden sich dann die Planeten. Dieses Bild wurde dann, sagen wir mal, ergänzt oder zum Teil auch revolutionär verändert, als man dann anfing, nicht nur die Gaspartikel in der Scheibe zu betrachten, sondern dann die gebildeten Planetesimale nachzuverfolgen. Das heißt also, ich bin sozusagen gegangen von der Vorstellung eines Kontinums.
Also Planetesimale sind sozusagen die ersten Verdichtungen, die dann letzten Endes sich wiederum zu Planeten zusammenführen.
Genau, und dann bin ich hingegangen zu diesen kleinen Körpern und ich habe jetzt also nicht mehr mit einer Gas-Scheibe zu tun, sondern ich habe es mit einer Wolke von kleinen Teilen zu tun, die dann miteinander wechselwirken. Also zum Beispiel kollidieren sie miteinander, zerstören sich gegenseitig, zum Teil aklomerieren sie und bilden größere und größere und größere und daraus bilden sich dann nachher die Planeten. Und da muss man also dem Kollegen Wetherill aus den USA das Verdienst zuweisen, dass er zum ersten Mal gezeigt hat, wenn ich so etwas dann rechne, dann habe ich eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Planet, der heute auf der Bahn des Merkur ist, gar nicht dort entstanden ist. Sondern dass der in der Spätphase der Bildung der Planeten durch Gravitationswechsel wirken, also nur am Vorbeiflug an dem Jupiter oder an anderen Planeten da hineingestreut worden ist und sich jetzt dort befindet. Und damit war sozusagen die einfache Theorie, einfach was heiß innen drin, kondensiert, war dann...
Das heißt, der Merkur ist überhaupt nicht da entstanden, wo er jetzt ist, sondern viel weiter draußen? Könnte sein.
Könnte sein. Könnte sein. Und das hat natürlich dann jetzt sofort die Theoretiker, die sich mit der Entstehung von Planeten beschäftigen, auf den Plan gemacht und gesagt, wir müssen mal dahin. Wir müssen mal uns nahe angucken, was hat der Merkur denn sonst noch zu bieten? An Volatilen beispielsweise.
Also an Stoffen, die sich vom Planeten entfernen?
Genau, also die flüchtig sind, an leicht flüchtigen Komponenten. Wir müssen uns den Merkur genauer angucken, um zu verstehen, was denn damals passiert ist. Ist der Merkur tatsächlich da entstanden, wo er sich heute befindet? Oder ist er später eingestreut worden? Also die erste Motivation, die man haben kann, wenn man sich jetzt fragt, warum soll ich da hin?
Ja, weil er auf einmal was ganz Besonderes geworden ist.
Er war auf einmal was ganz Besonderes geworden. Und man hat gesagt, da liegt ein Schlüssel zu unserem Verständnis des Sonnensystems. Welche Prozesse können also passieren in der Frühphase der Entwicklung? Gut, das ist sozusagen die eine Seite. Die andere Seite kommt so mehr aus der Richtung, wie ich persönlich komme. Der natürlich sich fragt, wie sieht denn so ein Planet eigentlich im Inneren aus? Okay, ich sollte vielleicht noch eins dazusagen. Diese chemische Anomalie ist nicht die einzige. Eine andere Anomalie ist noch, dass der Merkur ein Magnetfeld erzeugt. Du würdest mal sagen, die Erde hat auch ein Magnetfeld. Die Erde hat ein Magnetfeld, Venus hat keins, Mars hat keins, der Merkur hat eins.
Und das Magnetfeld entsteht bei der Erde vor allem aus der Bewegung im Inneren?
Ja, das Magnetfeld bei einem typischen terrestrischen Planeten, für den wir die Erde halten, entsteht.
Der Bauform Erde, ja.
Sozusagen, ja.
Obwohl ich mal zitiert worden bin, als ich in Violau bei der Amateur-Astronomentagung hatte ich einen Vortrag gehalten, da geht mir so eine Tagungszeitung raus. Und da sagten sie, Spohn behauptet, der Erde ist kein erdähnlicher Planet. Weil ich bei diesem Vortrag darauf hingewiesen hatte, wie groß doch die Unterschiede sind zwischen der Erde und den anderen terrestrischen Planeten, dass die sich eigentlich mehr untereinander ähneln als die Erde ähneln. Aber das ist jetzt wieder ein anderes Thema. Das Magnetfeld eines Planeten wird im Kern erzeugt. Davon dürfen wir ausgehen. Der Kern ist elektrisch leidend. Er besteht ja aus Eisen, haben wir vorhin ja schon gesagt. Wir wissen bei der Erde auch, dass der äußere Kern, also dass der Kern sich unterteilt in einen festen inneren Kern, einen flüssigen äußeren Kern. In diesem äußeren Kern kann ich mir vorstellen, gibt es Konvektionsströmungen. Und diese Konvektionsströmungen können letztlich Bewegungsenergie in magnetische Feldenergie umsetzen, sowie ein Fahrraddynamo Bewegungsenergie in elektrischem Strom umsetzt. Und dieser elektrische Strom, der dann in den Leitungen beim Fahrrad fließt, der hat auch ein Magnetfeld drum herum. Im Prinzip ist dieser Dynamo ganz, ganz ähnlich. Was man da macht, ist sozusagen, man nimmt an, es gibt ein Saatmagnetfeld. Das Saatmagnetfeld wird durch die Strömung da drin verzerrt. Durch die Verzerrung entsteht ein elektrischer Strom. Der elektrische Strom, nach dem Induktionsgesetz, hat wieder ein Magnetfeld. Wenn ich dann genügend Energie immer reinpumpe, kann ich also ein Magnetfeld erhalten. Und die magnetische Energie, die in dem Feld steckt, kann ich dann aus dieser Bewegungsenergie versorgen.
Das heißt, auf der einen Seite weiß man aber, dass das Ding ein starrer Planet ist, der seine Oberfläche nicht mehr ändert. Auf der anderen Seite hat er ein Magnetfeld. Das passt ja erstmal nicht zusammen.
Das passt vielleicht nur so vordergründig oder passt vordergründig nicht zusammen. Der Merkur in der Tat, also von außen, hat diese starre Hülle. Innen drin, dürfen wir davon ausgehen, hat er diesen Eisenkern, von dem wir gesprochen haben. Und dieser Eisenkern, davon dürfen wir auch ausgehen. Und das sagen wir aufgrund der Beobachtung dieses Magnetfelds, müsste flüssig sein, zumindest in Teilen. Gut, und jetzt kommen sozusagen dann die Klasse von Planetenforschern her, die sozusagen in meine Riege fallen. Wir interessieren uns natürlich dann dafür, wie kann es sein, dass also dieser Planet Merkur ein Magnetfeld erzeugt, wo doch der Kern so groß ist. Hat das mit der Größe des Kerns zu tun und die Silikardschicht dadrum so klein. Und wir möchten das gerne besser näher verstehen. Und dazu sind wir natürlich daran interessiert, zu vermessen, wie dieses Magnetfeld denn im Einzelnen aussieht, ob es so schön wie ein Startmagnet aufgebaut ist, wie wir das von der Erde kennen, oder ob es sehr viel komplexer aufgebaut ist und so weiter. Zumal man sagen muss, dass wir haben natürlich versucht, vorherzusagen, dann aus der Betrachtung der Erde und der anderen Plattform, versucht vorherzusagen, wie stark denn das Magnetfeld des Merkurs sein sollte. Wir glauben, wir verstehen, warum er ein Magnetfeld hat. Aber das Problem hat sich dann gestellt, dass was wir vorhersagen würden, wäre ein Magnetfeld, was deutlich stärker ist als das, was wir beobachten. Das heißt, wir haben ein Problem an der Stelle, dass wir zwar sagen können, wir verstehen, Merkur, warum du ein Magnetfeld hast, aber bitte erklär uns doch mal, warum das so schwach ist. Das sollte eigentlich stärker sein. Und das bedeutet auch wieder, dass man gerne dort hinfahren müsste und würde erkunden. Gut, dann gab es dann andere Kollegen, die sich mit der Chemie der Oberflächen gesteinete des Merkurs beschäftigt haben. Und auch im Hinblick auf die hohe Dichte, die dann letztendlich Modelle entwickelt haben, wie man verstehen kann, dass der Merkur dann, selbst wenn diese alte, das frühere Modell der Entstehung in diesem Temperaturgradienten nicht mehr stimmen sollte, wenn man trotzdem verstehen kann, dass der Merkur diese ungewöhnlich hohe Dichte hat, die haben dann gesagt, es gibt da verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Ein Teil des Merkurs könnte verdampft sein in der frühen Phase der Entstehung des Planeten. Andere haben gesagt, der Merkur könnte von einem ähnlich großen Planetesimal getroffen worden sein und dabei seine Silikathylle verloren haben. Zu einem Großteil, das also früher ähnlich aufgebaut gewesen ist wie die Erde, der Mars, die Venus, aber durch diese Kollision einen Gutteil seines Silikatmantels verloren hat. Oder er könnte aber in der Frühphase der Entstehung durch eine Tetauriphase der Sonne ein Teil des Materials weggepustet worden sein, was dann eigentlich dort vorhanden gewesen wäre.
Was für eine Phase der Sonne?
Tetauriphase. Das ist eine Phase, in der die Sonne in der Frühphase ihrer Entwicklung einen enorm starken Sonnenwind ausstößt, der als Explosionswelle durch das Sonnensystem fegt und dann eine Menge von Zeug mitnimmt. Da hat man dann Modelle entwickelt, die dann sagen würden, wenn ich jetzt an der Oberfläche die Zusammensetzung des Gesteins messen könnte, dann könnte ich zwischen diesen Entstehungshypothesen unterscheiden. Das ist sozusagen dann die dritte Motivation gewesen, dort hinzufliegen. Denn dann muss man halt einfach messen, was ist die Zusammensetzung und dann kann man dann halt sehen, ob das zu den Vorstellungen passt, die man dann hat. Und ich sag noch eine Vierte. Eine Vierte ist einfach die, dass die Leute, die sich für Magnetfelder als solches interessieren, die können am Merkur sozusagen die Wechselwirkung eines starken, sehr starken Magnetfels, der Sonne, jetzt mit dem Magnetfel des Merkurs studieren und dann einiges lernen über Plasmaphysik und Ausbreitung von magnetischen Wellen im Sonnensystem usw. Also das sind sozusagen so vier Hauptgründe, die man dann der ESA schmackhaft gemacht hat. Und offenbar sind wir erfolgreich gewesen. Denn tatsächlich hat man im Jahre 2001 oder so, hat man dann die Vision ausgewählt. Und das ist dann der nächste Cornerstone geworden. Und dann kam dann die Ausschreibung der Instrumente und dann kam dann die Phase, in der wir jetzt heute sind, in der die Instrumente dann fertig gebaut worden sind usw.
Es gibt ja, also wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, BepiColombo wird die dritte Mission sein. Messenger der NASA-Mission ist noch vor Ort. Vorher gab es nur die Mariner-Sonde, die vorbei flog, dabei einen Teil aufgenommen hat. Inwiefern hat sich denn dieses Bild des Merkur durch diese Mission immer wieder verändert?
Die Geschichte von Messenger ist noch nicht abgeschlossen. Das sind zurzeit wieder Publikationen in der Macher. Selbst dann ist die nominelle Phase der Mission vorbei. Wir gehen also in eine Extended-Mission rein. Dennoch hat es einiges gegeben, was unser Bild des Merkurs nachhaltig verändert hat. Zum einen haben wir zum ersten Mal eine komplette Abdeckung. Wir wissen, wie der Planet insgesamt aussieht. Wir haben darüber hinaus eine komplette Vermessung. Komplett kann man auch nicht so ganz sagen. Die Messenger-Bahn, muss man dazusagen, ist stark elliptisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob man an der Stelle einen Ausflug in Vergleich Messenger mit BepiColombo machen sollte. Messenger macht einen Kompromiss zwischen dem, was die beiden Orbiter der BepiColombo-Mission machen wollen. Einerseits will man den Planeten aus der Nähe erforschen. Das heißt, man muss nah dran. Auf der anderen Seite hat man dieses große Interesse an der Wechselwirkung des Magnetfills des Merkurs mit dem Magnetfill der Sonne und dem Sonnenwind. Dazu muss man eine Bahn haben, die möglichst viel von dem Magnetfeld erfasst. Das heißt, ich möchte gerne eine elliptische Bahn haben. Bei BepiColombo haben wir diesen Planetenorbiter, der eine niedrige Elliptizität hat, eine niedrige Bahnexzentrizität hat und möglichst nah am Planeten bleiben will. Wir haben auf der anderen Seite den MMO, den Magnetospheric Orbiter, der eine hohe Exzentrizität hat. Wenn man nahe zum Merkur fliegt, dann wird er weiter weg. Und MESSENGER macht einen Kompromiss aus beiden. Die Folge davon ist, dass MESSENGER sehr gut die Nordhemisphäre erforschen kann, aber weniger gut die Südhemisphäre. Das heißt also, an der Stelle werden sich die beiden Missionen dann sehr gut ergänzen. BepiColombo wird also das ergänzen können auf jeden Fall für die Südhemisphäre, was also bei MESSENGER jetzt für die Nordhemisphäre fehlt. Und wir haben bei BepiColombo auch andere und zum Teil auch verbesserte Instrumente, sodass wir sagen können, das macht eine Menge Sinn, dass wir, wir sind da jetzt so ein bisschen arrogant, dass wir sagen, okay, MESSENGER ist unser Pathfinder und wenn die richtige Mission, die kommt dann mit BepiColombo. Aber gut, das ist halt unser Blick auf die Dinge. Gut, aber MESSENGER hat also jetzt durchaus die Nordhemisphäre des Merkurs gut erforscht. Hat also dann zum Beispiel herausgefunden, dass das Magnetfeld des Merkurs asymmetrisch zu sein scheint. Was jetzt nun wiederum Randbedingungen liefert für diejenigen, die jetzt versuchen zu verstehen, wie denn das Magnetfeld des Merkurs erzeugt wird.
Was heißt das, es ist asymmetrisch?
Na ja, es sieht so aus als ob, also wenn ich da in den Merkur einen Startmagnet hineintun möchte, das ist ja sozusagen das Idealtypus eines Magnetfelds. Nordpol, Südpol und die Feldlinien verbinden sich.
So wie man es grob auch bei der Erde hat.
In der Erde kann ich mir vorstellen, in einer ersten Annäherung an eine Darstellung des Erdmagnetfelds, ich setze in das Zentrum der Erde einen Startmagnet rein und kippe den leicht, weil wir ja eine Missweisung haben. Wir kennen das denn, der magnetische Nordpol ist nicht der gleiche wie der geografische. Der Rotationspol ist noch mal ein anderer. Ich habe also diese Verschiebung in der Achseneigung, dieses Deep-Polt gegenüber der Rotationsachse. Das ist eine typische Verfahrensweise, die ich also mache, wenn ich planetare Magnetfelder erstmal charakterisiere. Und nun ist es so, dass dieser äquivalente Stabmagnet, den man da reinsetzen würde, doch ein gut Stück aus dem Zentrum des Merkurs verschoben ist. Zuletzt würde man sagen, das ist nicht so schlimm, aber es ist mehr, als man sich das gedacht hätte. Was darauf hindeutet, dass irgendwas mit der Magnetfelderzeugung da funny ist, also merkwürdig ist. Es könnte beispielsweise sein, also eine erste Erklärung, die ich jetzt zum Beispiel so haben würde, ist, dass das Magnetfeld des Merkurs nicht sehr tief im Innern des Planeten erzeugt wird, so wie das bei der Erde der Fall ist, sondern vielleicht in den Außenbereichen dieses großen Kerns.
Ja, aber hatten wir nicht eh schon festgehalten, dass es innen wahrscheinlich eher ein fester Kern ist, außen ist er flüssig, und dieses Flüssige ist ja letztlich verantwortlich für die Bildung des Magnetfelds, dann bedient sich das doch gerade so.
Wir haben aber nicht darüber gesprochen, wie groß dieser innere Kern sein würde. Also wir haben bei der Erde davon gesprochen, da gibt es einen festen inneren Kern, einen flüssigen äußeren Kern. Ich würde sagen, wir stellen uns mal Merkurs Endes vor. Der wird jetzt auch einen festen inneren Kern haben, der dadurch entsteht, dass der Kern insgesamt aus einem insgesamt flüssigen Zustand abkühlt und anfängt in einen festen inneren Kern auszufrieren, in der Wächstenlauf der Zeit. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie groß dieser innere Kern ist, dieser feste innere Kern. Ich habe keine Vorstellung davon. Ich hoffe, mit BepiColombo da möglicherweise Hinweise zu finden, wie ich das bestimmen könnte. Muss nicht gelingen, kann gelingen. Und wenn dieser innere Kern nun klein ist, ich sage es mal, hat vielleicht ein Radius von 100, 200 Kilometern, dann ist er im Vergleich zum Radius des Merkurs, könnte es sein, dass das Magnetfeld tief innen erzeugt wird. Also 200 Kilometer sind etwa 10 Prozent von 2000, rund Pima Daum, Radius des Merkurs, dann wäre er tief drin. Wenn aber das Magnetfeld in den äußeren Bereichen des Kerns erzeugt wird, also bei 800 Kilometer Radius, dann ist das relativ nah an der Oberfläche. Wir wissen jetzt, wenn wir Magnetfelder nicht nur durch diesen Stabmagneten repräsentieren wollen, sondern in der vollen Schönheit repräsentieren wollen, dann stellen wir fest, dass also dieses Stabmagnetfeldbild nicht vollständig ist, sondern dass das Veränderungen und das Überlagerungen da drin sind von anderen Figuren, also von einem Kreuzdipol und höherer Thermo, dass das Feld sehr viel komplexer ausgeprägt ist, als einfach nur dieses Stabmagnetfeld repräsentiert würde. Und wenn ich dann in so einem komplexeren Feld versuche, ein Stabmagnetfeld hineinzulegen, dann finde ich oft, dass der dann verschoben ist aus dem Inneren. Das haben wir beim Uranus, beim Nettoon gesehen, wo das Feld so aussieht, als wenn ich es jetzt durch ein Stabmagnet repräsentieren will. Als müsste ich diesen Stabmagnetfeld relativ weit draußen, weg vom Zentrum, relativ nah an der Oberfläche platzieren. Also verschoben aus dem Inneren. Das heißt also, es könnte sein, wie beim Uranus und Nettoon, so auch bei Merkur, dass diese komplexere Form des Magnetfelds ein Hinweis darauf ist, dass das Feld relativ weit draußen in dem Kern erzeugt wird. Also nicht tief im Zentrum des Planeten, sondern in den Außenbereichen dieses großen Eisenkerns. Wäre also eine Erklärung. Vielleicht noch ein Wort dazu, warum das dann so aussieht. Also wenn man jetzt die einzelnen Beiträge zu dem Bild des Magnetfeldes analysiert, dann stellt man fest, dass ein Magnetfeld, das sehr komplex in der Nähe aussehen kann, je weiter weg ich gehe, dann ähnelt es immer mehr diesem typischen Startmagnetfeld. Also auch eine Frage der Beobachtungsentfernung von dem Gebiet, in dem ich das Magnetfeld erzeuge. Also je näher ich drankomme, kann man sich vielleicht vorstellen, desto komplexer sieht es aus, je weiter ich weggehe, desto mehr sehe ich diesen Startmagneten vor mir.
Der Merkur ist ja nun durch seine extreme Nähe zur Sonne eben jeder massiv ausgesetzt. Das heißt der Sonnenwind, die Hitze, die Gravitation kommt natürlich dann auch noch mit dazu. Die Erde wiederum hat es da ein bisschen leichter, aber auch das Magnetfeld trägt ja dazu bei, sich eben vor der Sonne zu schützen. Der Sonnenwind wird abgeleitet, man hat dann diese schöne Aurora, vor allem am Nordpol. Das schützt ja auch die Atmosphäre. So etwas wie eine Atmosphäre hat der Merkur nicht zu bieten.
Er hat also eine ganz dünne, natriumreiche Atmosphäre, wenn ich es jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe. Die hat also die Eigenschaft einer Exosphäre. Das heißt also, in dieser Atmosphäre ist eigentlich die mittlere freie Weglänge sehr groß. Das ist eigentlich eher nahe einem idealen Gas als den Zustand, den wir in unserer tiefen Atmosphäre haben. Wenn wir jetzt hier die Atmosphäre beschreiben, dann sprechen wir ja dann auch mehr als von einem Fluid, also Fluideneigenschaften. Nur in den äußersten Bereichen unserer Atmosphäre haben wir dann sozusagen sehr freie Weglängen und einzelne Moleküle, die dann zu betrachten wären. Und so ist es bei Merkur. Also eine ganz dünne Atmosphäre, die nicht sehr dicht ist.
Wie auch der Mars.
Der Mars hat eine deutlich dichtere Atmosphäre.
Okay, also noch mal schwächer.
Noch mal deutlich schwächer als die Atmosphäre.
Das heißt, dieses Magnetfeld, vielleicht auch durch seine Asymmetrie und sein erratisches Verhalten, wirkt überhaupt nicht schützend und fördernd?
Nö, diese Physik der Wechselwirkungen, also des Schutzes der Atmosphäre durch das Magnetfeld, das würde ich jetzt mal in dieser Art und Weise nicht übertragen. Ich bin an der Stelle auch nicht genügend Experte in der Exosphäre des Merkurs, dass ich jetzt sagen könnte, wie jetzt im Einzelnen die Wechselwirkungen da sind. Also ich stelle mir vor, das sind Wechselwirkungen, kann die aber jetzt nicht wirklich sehr vernünftig beschreiben. Aber es ist sicherlich nicht das Gleiche, wie wir das jetzt bei der Erde beobachten, dass wir sozusagen durch das Magnetfeld dann einen Schutz dieser Hülle haben, der Lufthülle sozusagen, mit der wir jetzt hier leben. Das sind ganz andere Verhältnisse dazu. Also dann die Atmosphäre in Anführungszeichen des Merkurs. Also viel zu dünn und viel zu, ja, viel zu dünn, sollten wir sagen.
Das heißt ja, Merkur ist der Sonne eigentlich schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Der ist im Wesentlichen der Sonnenstrahlung schutzlos ausgeliefert, was ja dann auch bewirkt, dass die Temperatur des Merkurs nur so stark variiert. Dazwischen, ich glaube, 30, 40 Kelvin etwa in der Gegend. Also auf der Nachtseite und 600 Kelvin, das sind also 400 Grad Celsius auf der Sonnenzugewandten Seite. Das sind schon starke Schwankungen der Temperatur, die wir da haben. Und denen, der Merkur dann ausgesucht, sind übrigens auch die Instrumente, die wir auf der Mission haben, die sich vor diesen enormen Strahlen Belastungen schützen muss. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt durch die Messenger-Mission eine Reihe von Phänomenen auf der Oberfläche gesehen, die wir sonst von anderen Planeten nicht erkennen. Das sind so genaue Löcher, die so in der Formation auf der Oberfläche sind. Und als ob da was eingestürzt sei.
Also nicht wie Krater?
Nee, nicht wie Krater, sondern wie scharf begrenzte Löcher in der Oberfläche. Und es wird darüber spekuliert, ob das letztlich Folgen der Wechselwirkung mit der Sonnenstrahlung sind, in der Art und Weise, die wir jetzt noch nicht verstehen.
So als wäre da irgendwie so ein Blitz eingeschlagen und hätte einfach ein Loch reingebrannt?
Ja, vielleicht so. Ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht ganz sicher, wie man... Wir haben also kein gutes Modell der Genese dieser.
Aber man weiß, dass diese Löcher existieren.
Man sieht die als morphologische Elemente. Wir sehen also diese scharf begrenzten Stellen auf der Oberfläche, die ganz offenbar Vertiefungen sind, die aber keine Einschlagrater sind in der Morphologie, die wir von Einschlagratern kennen. Und wir haben also keine Vorstellungen, wie die jetzt nun da entstanden sein könnten. Also das ist also eins der Rätsel. Und wie gesagt, es gibt...
Wie tief und groß muss man diese Löcher... Sind das jetzt so Kleinstöffnungen, die dann ganz tief sind?
Nee, die sind also durchaus im Kilometerbereich und mehr. Das sind so richtige...
Die Breite jetzt?
In ihrem Radius. Oder Durchmesser. Also in dieser Gegend, das ist ein ganz Spektrum von Dingen, die wir da sehen. Man hätte auch denken können, es sind Einschlagrater, aber die Morphologie, das scheint sich eben signifikant von Einschlagratern. Insofern können wir nicht sagen, dass es Einschlagrater sind.
Weiß man, wie tief die sind?
Die sind in etwa so tief, wie sie auch aussehen. Das lässt verboten, dass sie in etwa so tief sind, wie auch ihre Ausdehnung ist.
Okay, also Kilometer, zwei Kilometer breit und genauso tief. Aber einfach so reingestanzt.
Oder ein Teil davon, also nicht in der Größenordnung.
Als wenn man mit dem Hammer in die Erde haut.
Als hätte man jetzt mit dem Hammer Löcher in eine Erdkruste gehauen, die außen fest ist, aber es zulässt, dass man diese Löcher dann holt.
Das heißt, der Merkur ist so eine einzige Lochkarte.
Naja, nun, also so holen wir sie jetzt ab. Gut, und dann hat man also noch, im Schwerefeld hat man Besonderheiten, die wir jetzt ohne Weiteres nicht verstehen. Also dann gibt es also eine Ebene nahe des Nordpols, die als so etwas abgeflacht ist. Von dem war es jetzt nicht im Aufblick, ohne was zu verstehen, wie die da entstanden ist. Also man kann sagen, Messenger hat uns ein detaillierteres Bild des Planeten gegeben. Hat sicherlich grob bestätigt, was wir also vorher wussten, dass es also eine alte Oberfläche ist. Aber sie hat mir also auch Details geliefert, wie zum Beispiel diese merkwürdigen Löcher und auch die Morphologie des Schwerfels, was man umsetzen kann in einer Kostenmächtigkeitskarte und so weiter. Und sie hat gezeigt, das hat jetzt möglicherweise auch etwas mit den Löchern zu tun, dass doch volatile, also flüchtige Bestandteile einen größeren Anteil an der Entwicklung der Oberfläche des Merkurs haben könnten, als wir das bisher uns gedacht haben. Also der Merkur ist wohl nicht vollkommen oder weitgehend volatilfrei und refraktär, so wie wir uns das vorher geglaubt haben. Da ist noch eine Menge zu tun, aber es gibt Hinweise dahingehend, dass das Bild des Merkurs wesentlich komplexer ist, als wir das bisher schon bestanden haben.
Was sind die Eigenschaften in einem Planet refraktär?
Refraktär heißt also, dass die schwerflüchtigen Bestandteile dominieren. Was könnte das sein? Es könnte vielleicht doch Eis geben in dem Regulitren. Es könnte vielleicht Schwefelverbindungen geben.
Eis, was sich hält bei 400 Grad Celsius?
In der größeren Tiefe oder in den polnaren Gebieten.
Die dann vielleicht doch durch irgendein Ereignis auf der Sonne weggedampft sind und dann stürzt alles ein. Dann hat man ein Loch. Ich darf ja spekulieren. Der Wissenschaftler muss noch mit den Schultern zucken.
Ich halte mich da jetzt mal ein bisschen zurück. Also sind die Verhältnisse dort wesentlich komplexer, als man sich das vorgestellt hat. Was natürlich für uns bedeutet, für BepiColombo, dass es da noch eine Menge offene Fragen gibt. Natürlich wird sich das noch entwickeln. Wir erwarten jetzt eigentlich die nächste Welle von Artikeln von den Kollegen. Von denen übrigens zwei aus dem Messenger-Team sind also auch hier im Haus. Wir erwarten also noch weitere Erkenntnisse davon, die wir jetzt so um einstelndlich haben. Da gibt es also erstmal so ein Embargo, bis das dann rauskommt, wenn das kompliziert ist, dann kann man das auch nachlesen und dann kann man das dann sehen. Bei solchen Missionen werden die Erkenntnisse in Schüben rausgegeben.
Erstmal dürfen die Teams da richtig drüber nachdenken.
Genau.
Nachvollziehbar. So, das heißt, wenn man das mal so zusammenfasst, der Merkur unterscheidet sich einerseits natürlich jetzt dadurch, dass er eben der Nächste ist, so nah an der Sonne ist, dass er auch extrem schwer zu erreichen ist. Dieses schöne Murmelbeispiel, da ist nur so eine ganz kleine Delle in der großen Schüssel und die muss man irgendwie genau treffen und auch mit der richtigen Geschwindigkeit, dass man dann auch da drin bleibt. Es gibt diverse Auffälligkeiten. Auf der einen Seite ist er so starr wie der Mond. Auf der anderen Seite hat er trotzdem ein Magnetfeldschein, also doch irgendwie so einen lebendigen Anteil zu haben, tief in ihm drin, der sich dann aber wieder ganz anders verhält als bei der Erde. Die Oberfläche selber kommt dann auch noch irgendwie schräg rüber, indem sie irgendwie so ausgestanzt ist. Wie viele von diesen Löchern gibt es denn eigentlich? Sind das nur ein paar oder ganz viele?
Das sind einige, wobei ich im Augenblick nicht eine Statistik sagen könnte, wie stark die jetzt da...
Und sind die gleichmäßig verteilt oder befinden die sich alle an einem Ort?
Das müsste man jetzt nochmal nachgucken. Auf jeden Fall sind es so die großen Rätsel, an denen man jetzt gerade so knabbert. Das ist etwas, woran man knabbert. Es gibt drei Dinge, von denen ich jetzt nur ein Erkenntnis habe, an denen man knabbert. Das sind also einerseits diese Geschichten, andererseits das Asymmetrische Magnetfeld und andererseits die etwas merkwürdige Form des schweren Felsen in der Nähe des Nahtpols, was auf eine nicht gleichmäßige Verteilung der Krustenmächtigkeit dann hindeutet. Aber da muss man auch mal sehen, was sich da am Einzelnen noch ergibt. Aber ich wollte noch mal den Punkt aufgreifen, bevor es also dazu um Missverständnis kommt, den Sie gerade eben machten. Also die harte äußere Schale und der weiche Kern. Man sollte sich jetzt nicht der Fehleinschätzung erliegen, dass der Mond durch und durch hart sei. So ist es nicht. Wir gehen schon davon aus, dass so ein Planet wie der Merkur, wie der Mond jetzt eine äußere Schale haben, die so hart sind, ich darf das Wort jetzt mal benutzen, dass sie die Einschlagszeugnisse noch tragen. Die sind also nicht überprägt worden durch vulkanische Aktivität oder durch Erosionsaktivität oder durch möglicherweise auch Relaxation. Was man sich prinzipiell vorstellen kann, die Sekrate, dass die einfach wieder sich auflösen. Das beobachten wir bei den Eismonden zum Teil. Aber dennoch ist es so, auch wenn ich im Mond in das tiefe Innere reingehe, wird der immer wärmer und auch immer weicher innen drin. Also ich darf mir durchaus auch vorstellen, dass im Zentrum des Mondes ein kleinerer, deutlich kleinerer, aber auch aus Eisen und möglicherweise flüssiger Kern sitzt. Möglicherweise auch mit einem festen, aber wiederum festen inneren Kern. Wenn ich den Merkur und den Mond auf dem Niveau vergleiche, muss ich allerdings sagen, sie stellen zwei Extreme dar. Also der Merkur hat mir beschrieben als ein Körper mit einem großen Eisenkern und einem relativ dünnen Mantel, während der Mond einen kleinen Eisenkern hat und einen sehr vergleichsweise dicken Mantel. Das sind sozusagen die Unterschiede, die wir jetzt hier haben. Aber diese Kerne sind sowohl im Mond wahrscheinlich, als auch im Merkur flüssig. Ich muss mich noch einmal korrigieren. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, der Kernradius, hatte ich mal an einer Stelle gesagt 1800 Kilometer ist in etwa der Kernradius. Und beim Mond sind es eben 300 Kilometer. Also wir vergleichen sozusagen einen Körper wie den Merkur mit rund 2400 Kilometer Radius, 1800 Kilometer Kernradius, 600 Kilometer Manteldicke, Steinsticke, mit einem Körper, der die gleiche oder eine ähnliche äußere Aussehen hat, wie den Mond, mit 1700 Kilometer Radius und nur 300 Kilometer Eisen-Kernmächtigkeit. Insofern muss man sich also jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass die dann durchgefroren sind, dass die innen drin weich sind und dynamisch aktiv sind. Das also ist durchaus den von vornherein zugestanden. Die Frage ist letztendlich, was treibt an, dass die Oberfläche verändert wird? Wie kommt vulkanische Aktivität dann zustande? Und das hängt natürlich auch mit der Entwicklung des Innern zusammen.
Eine Frage, die sich ja auch immer stellt, wenn man jetzt auf das Sonnensystem schaut und die ganzen Planeten erforscht, ist ja auch immer so die Frage, warum macht man das eigentlich? Es gibt ja so viel dabei zu entdecken, dass die Erforschung anderer Planeten auch eine ganze Menge Antworten liefert für unseren Planeten, weil man ja überhaupt erstmal den Vergleich hat. In gewisser Hinsicht kann man ja andere Planeten ganz anders beobachten als unsere eigene Erde. Aber in letzter Zeit hat ja auch so die Exoplanetenforschung enorm angezogen, vor allem jetzt durch die neuen Instrumente. Das Kepler-Teleskop ist da wahrscheinlich vor allem zu nennen, sodass man ja jetzt einiger Zeit sicher sagen kann, es gibt nicht nur andere Planeten, sondern es gibt verdammt viele davon. Und auf der Suche nach Planeten, die jetzt ähnlich wie die Erde in der habitablen Zone, das ist natürlich das Spannendste irgendwie, sind doch die meisten, die bisher entdeckt wurden, relativ nah an ihren Sonnen dran.
Das liegt einfach daran, was die Entdeckungstechnologie, die bevorzugt, die nah dran sind. Also einerseits haben wir ja dann die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode, bei der der Planet an dem Stern sozusagen zupft. Das heißt also, dass er seine Gravitation so eiern lässt. Was dann als Dopplersignal zu messen ist. Aus diesen Wechselwirkungen kann ich dann letztlich die Masse des Planeten, also die Kraft, mit der er sozusagen zupft, kann ich dann also feststellen. Beziehungsweise das andere sind die Bedeckungsexperimente der Beobachtungen. Die Transition, wenn er direkt davor läuft. Da kann ich den Radius draus abschätzen. Aber auch da hab ich es gerne, wenn er relativ nah bei ist, weil er dann den Transit relativ oft macht. Wenn ich den Neptune beobachten würde von weit weg, dann hab ich in meiner Lebenszeit sehr geringe Chance, die Beobachtung zu bestätigen. Das ist bei den Exoplaneten auch notwendig, dass man die Beobachtung bestätigt.
Ich glaube, der Merkur ist derjenige, wenn jemand anders auf unser System schaut und nach Planeten sucht, dann weiß ich nicht genau, welche Planeten am meisten dafür qualifizieren, als erste entdeckt zu werden. Aber vermutlich ist es auch der Merkur. Wenn man sich den Merkur anschaut und die Exoplaneten, die man jetzt schon entdeckt hat, weil sie so nah dran sind, müsste es ja auch Ähnlichkeiten geben können.
Ja, möglicherweise würden wir auch den Jupiter als Erster entdecken. Das ist natürlich schon richtig, was sie ansprechen. Wir haben es mit diesen Planeten zu tun, hauptsächlich die, die wir beobachten, die relativ nah an ihrem Zentralstern sind. Leider ist es zurzeit noch so, dass wir eine ganze Reihe von Kepler-Kandidaten haben. Ich glaube, die Zahl liegt bei 3.000 oder so. Die sind nicht bestätigt, sondern das sind Kandidaten für Planeten. Da wird sicherlich ein Gutteil davon werden, letztendlich auch bestätigt werden können, falls man die so lange beobachten würde. Manche davon kann man auch nie bestätigen, weil sie zumindest nicht in einer fündlichen Lebenszeit bestätigen, weil sie dann zu weit von ihrem Zentralstern wachsen. Aber was wir bestätigt haben, das sind eine Zahl von rund 800 Planeten. Aber es gibt relativ wenige davon, von denen wir tatsächlich die Dichte wissen. Das heißt also Masse und Radius. Von denen wir sagen können, wir haben eine gewisse Vorstellung davon, was das ist. Also ist das jetzt ein Gasplanet, der eine Dichte von 2 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter oder 1 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter mehr haben würde, so wie der Jupiter oder Uranus und Neptun? Beziehungsweise ist das ein Gesteinsplanet, der eine Dichte von 5 oder mehr haben würde, weil es in der Regel doch sehr viel größere Planeten sind, sogenannte Supererden. Die haben dann auch noch eine höhere Dichte, also die geht dann bis 6 oder 7 oder so was in den Drehungen. Und da gibt es zwei, die sich für den Vergleich mit dem Merkur besonders eignen. Das ist einmal Coro 7b und Kepler 10b. Das sind zwei Planeten, von denen wir wissen, das sind Gesteinskörper und wir wissen, sie sind relativ nah dran. Und man hat jetzt auch hier im Hause Modelle gemacht, mit denen man jetzt aus der Dichte, aus der mittleren Dichte heraus, unter der Annahme, dass die letztendlich aus einem Gemisch von Gestein und Eisen bestehen, hat man sich gefragt, wenn ich mir das nun so vorgebe, wie groß wäre dann der Radius, der Eisenradius dieser Körper? Und da findet man interessanterweise raus unter den gegebenen Unsicherheiten, die das hat, dass die auch relativ große Eisenkerne haben würden. Das heißt, dass sie auch relativ angereichert sind an Eisen im Vergleich zu der Erde und Venus und so weiter. Also sie ähneln eher dem Merkur in dieser Hinsicht als der Erde und der Venus.
Auch von ihrer Position relativ zu stellen.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Was interessant ist, im Hinblick auf die Frage, hat die Position des Merkurs was mit seiner Zusammensetzung zu tun? Auch diese beiden Planeten sind nah an ihrem Zentralstand, sind eigentlich noch näher an ihrem Zentralstand als der Merkur. Und würde jetzt in dieser Debatte um die chemische Zusammensetzung des Merkurs, wie hängt das zusammen mit Entstehungsmitteln und so weiter, weitere Hinweise geben, dass es offenbar noch das eine oder andere Mal mehr vorkommt, dass ein Planet, der nah bei seinem Zentralstand ist, einen relativ hohen Eisenunterhalt hat. Mehr kann man im Augenblick nicht sagen, denn man hat in diesem System keine Statistik über die anderen Körper da drin. Man hat nicht genügend Daten, um da jetzt eine große Statistik machen zu können, aber es ist interessant der Hinweis, dass das bei den beiden auch so ist.
Ja, Kuro ist ja das andere Teleskop, was Exoplaneten entdeckt. Das hatte ich jetzt ganz vergessen, neben Kepler, vor allem die beiden Entdeckungssysteme zu sein.
Ja gut, also die Kepler hatten, wenn man so will, das muss man sagen aus europäischer Sicht, ist vielleicht bedauerlich Kuro so ein bisschen die Schau gestohlen, weil es eben später technologisch weiterentwickelt hat, also auch eine andere Beobachtungsgeometrie und kann halt eine Menge mehr Planeten detektieren, oder zumindest Kandidaten detektieren, mit einer höheren Rate als das Kuro kann. Und wir hoffen natürlich, dass wir das jetzt nun wiederum toppen können mit einer unserer nächsten ESA-Missionen. Da sind ja zwei Exoplaneten-Missionen in der Diskussion. Das eine ist PLATO, an dem wir an diesem Institut ein großes Interesse daran haben, weil wir hier dann die wissenschaftliche Leiterin der gesamten Mission haben würden, also Frau Rauer, Frau Kollegin Rauer. Diese Mission würde also weiter Transits beobachten und dann vor allen Dingen auch das Feld erkunden, was also jetzt eine ganze Reihe von diesen Planeten enthält, die durch die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode entdeckt oder beobachtet worden sind, wo man dann die Masse kennt und man würde den Radius dazu liefern, hätte dann auf einmal eine sehr viel größere Datenbasis mit Mittler und Dichten für Exoplaneten. Die andere Mission, die in Konkurrenz ist, ist die Mission Echo, die hauptsächlich auf die Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre zielt. Und wenn ich jetzt richtig weiß...
Also von Exoplaneten.
Von Exoplaneten. Dann stärker auf Jupiter-ähnliche Planeten fokussiert ist als Plato das ist. Da kann man sicherlich debattieren, was Echo da noch alles kann. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall...
Aber es sind jetzt noch keine beschlossenen Missionen?
Nein, das sind Missionen, die sind also im Konkurrenz mit anderen Missionen um die sogenannten M3-Gelegenheit. Missionsfluggelegenheit. Also die nächste mittlere Mission, die die ESA dann fliegen wird. Also wir haben ja da zurzeit das M1 und M2, die sind ja beschlossen. Das ist einmal der Solar Orbiter, also ein Orbiter um die Sonne. Das andere ist Euclid, die Mission, die jetzt nach der Dark Energy, also dunklen Energie erforschen möchte. Und dann haben wir die erste L-Mission, das ist also Juice. Und zurzeit läuft also der Wettbewerb um die M3-Fluggelegenheit. Die dritte in dieser Reihe in diesem Programm. Und da konkurrieren dann beispielsweise PLATO und ECHO, aber auch eine Röntgen-Astronomie-Mission und Marco Polo, also ein Flug zu einem Asteroiden. Und da mögen noch ein paar andere sein.
Dass das alles noch offen?
Ja.
Ja, stellt sich so ein bisschen an, in Betracht der Tatsache, dass BepiColombo ja noch nicht mal gestartet ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich fast schon ein bisschen vermessen, da noch weiter in die Zukunft zu schauen. Speziell was so den Merkur betrifft. Gibt es denn da überhaupt eine inswerte Überlegung? Oder ist erstmal alles ausgeblendet?
Naja, also im Augenblick gibt es, zumindest mir ist es nicht bekannt, dass es nun weitere Pläne gibt, mit Missionen den Merkur zu erforschen. Was nicht heißt, dass noch Aufgaben offen sind. Also es wird auch nach BepiColombo noch Interesse an Merkur geben, es wird offene Fragen geben. Wobei man sicherlich sagen kann, die Fragen stellen sich oft dann auch bei der Beobachtung. Also wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel festgestellt mit Messenger, diese Anormalitäten bezüglich des Magnetfelds, diese merkwürdigen Löcher, über die wir gesprochen haben. Das sind Dinge, die man sich vorher so nicht vorgestellt hat. Und die dann sozusagen aufgeworfen sind. Und so wird es sicherlich auch so sein, schätze ich mal, dass auch BepiColombo neue Fragen aufwirft. Aber was wir damals schon, als wir ursprünglich die BepiColombo-Mission geplant hatten, da hatten wir ungefähr drei Missionselemente. Also wir hatten diese beiden Arbeiter und wir hatten das Surface-Element. Das heißt also ein Lander, der dann auf der Oberfläche mit einem mobilen Payload, also sollte dann einerseits Messungen in der Gebung des Landers machen, aber auch dann mit einem kleinen Fahrzeug dann rumfahren, chemische Analyse der Gesteine machen, beispielsweise mit einem elektromechanischen Maulwurf den Boden eindringen und dann den Wärmefluss aus dem Inneren des Merkur-Messens und so weiter. Dieses Element der Mission musste damals gestrichen werden, einerseits aus finanziellen Gründen, andererseits aber auch, weil eine Missionsanalyse ergeben hat, dass man, um auf dem Merkur zu landen, so viel Breitstoff mitnehmen muss, dass in dem Budget, was in der Mission damals zur Verfügung gestellt worden war an Masse und Energie, was man hatte, man eigentlich gar keine wissenschaftlichen Nutzlasten mehr dorthin bringen konnte. Insofern lag es dann also nahezu sagen, naja gut, unter den gegebenen Umständen können wir also eine Landung auf dem Merkur nicht realisieren. Das muss dann ein Element einer möglichen zukünftigen Erforschung des Merkurs an der Oberfläche sein. Das würde natürlich dann auch der Strategie, die man ja so ganz generell hat bei der Erforschung von Planeten, dass man zunächst mit dem Atten vorbei flog. Das haben wir mit den Marineson gehabt. Dann haben wir Arbiter, das sind also Messenger und BepiColombo. Der nächste logische Schritt, the next logical step. Das ist ja so ein Wort, was die ESA gerne gebraucht, in allen möglichen Gelegenheiten. The next logical step ist dann eine Landung auf dem Merkur und eine Erforschung des Planeten in situ.
Wäre denn da überhaupt so etwas Vergleichbares? Wir sind fast beim Anfang der Sendung angekommen, wie die Marsrover sowas auf dem Merkur überhaupt zu leisten, bei diesen unfassbaren hohen Temperaturunterschieden. Gibt es überhaupt eine Stelle, wo man sich davor verstecken kann? Gibt es eine Stelle, die nicht regelmäßig beschieden wird?
Na ja, man könnte sicherlich in der Nähe des Nordpols landen. Da mag es dann auch Gegenden geben. Ich bin mir sicher, ob es da Points of Eternal Shadow geben. Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob man da unbedingt hin will. Das hat natürlich Interesse wegen Eis. In diesen Gegenden könnte man dann...
Wie auf dem Mond sozusagen...
.ein Eis suchen. Mag sein, dass man da ein Interesse daran haben würde. Auf der anderen Seite damals, die Pläne zielten eigentlich mehr auf eine mehr äquaturnahe Landestelle. Und man hat dann also sich überlegt, was man eigentlich tun könnte, damit man sozusagen den Rover fit macht, dafür, dass er die Temperaturen auf dem Merkur dann eben er tragen kann. Und die Überlegungen sind dann nicht so frisch bei weit gedient, weil man relativ früh in der Planungsphase dann gesehen hat, dass das eh nun kein Thema im Augenblick ist. Und da ist man also nicht so frisch bei weit gekommen. Aber es bestand schon eigentlich die, nehme ich mal an, berechtigte Hoffnung, auch gestützt von den Ingenieuren, die mit uns da ja dran gearbeitet hatten, eine Definition eines Surface-Elements, dass man das in den Griff kriegen würde. Und dann halt eben so bauen könnte, dass es dann eben die Temperaturen dort aushält.
Na ja, Sonnenenergie gibt es zumindest eine Menge?
Sonnenenergie gibt es genug. Das Problem, das wir natürlich jetzt haben, ist, das hat damit auch BepiColombo zu kämpfen, dass die hohe UV-Strahlung, die man da hat, zerstört die Sonnenzellen. Das wusste man damals noch nicht.
Was wusste man nicht?
Dass die Solarzellen so empfindlich auf die UV-Strahlung reagieren würden. Das ist also eines der Erkenntnisse gewesen, die man im Laufe der Entwicklung für BepiColombo gemacht hat. Und die also auch zu Verzögerungen, Missionsverzögerungen und Kostensteigerungen beigetragen hat. Das ist etwas, womit man immer rechnen muss bei diesen Missionen. Dass ich Dinge entdecke, also nicht nur wissenschaftliche Dinge, die ich nicht erwartet habe, sondern auch technische Dinge, die ich nicht erwartet habe. Diese Empfindlichkeit für UV ist eines davon. Da kann man ja nicht sagen, dass man das nachprüfen könnte. Aber das hat man ja auch. Nur hat man sich nicht gedacht, dass es so sein wird. Das hat man im Laufe der Zeit herausgefunden. Das führt heute dazu, dass wir die Sonnenpanels nur vorsichtig der Sonnenbelastung aussetzen können. Das würde sicherlich auch für dieses Surface-Element Rückwirkungen gehabt haben. Aber das müssen dann zukünftige Studien zeigen, was man dann am besten macht und wo man dann am besten hingeht. Da wird es dann auch, wie es bei solchen Missionen immer ist, eine Debatte darüber geben und darüber, was die wissenschaftlichen Ziele sind, wie man einzelne Ziele gegeneinander abwägt. Also Interessen beispielsweise in permanenten Schattengebieten zu operieren oder dann doch lieber am Äquator. Das muss man alles überlegen. Dazu kommen dann Missionsanalysen dazu und technische Randbedingungen und so weiter. So wird man sich dann irgendwie zusammenraufen müssen und dann eine Mission definieren, die dann Merkur zum ersten Mal in situ erforscht wird.
Nehmen wir mal an, das wäre jetzt alles technisch und finanziell auch lösbar. Es würde jetzt irgendwas hinfliegen, was vielleicht noch mal sechs Jahre unterwegs ist. Was würde denn so ein Rover vermutlich vorfinden an der Oberfläche? Kann man davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt nicht nur so aussieht wie der Mond und strukturell so ähnlich ist wie der Mond? Ist es dann auch so eine ähnliche Staubslandschaft? Weiß man das überhaupt? Ist das dann so wie auf Mars? Kann man da so problemlos rumfahren? Oder ist man erst mal froh, dass man überhaupt erst mal gelandet ist und bleibt dann da liegen?
Also das wäre natürlich rauszufinden. Aber ich denke, von dem, was wir heute wissen, wir würden erwarten, dass dort ein Regolith ist. Das heißt, so eine staubige Oberfläche, wie wir das vom Mond her eher kennen, als das, was da vom Mars her ist, wo es da auch staubig ist. Wir würden jetzt einfach mal sagen, wir können eher den Mond übertragen auf den Merkur, als jetzt den Mars auf den Merkur.
Wie ist die Gravitation?
Die Gravitation ist deutlich schwächer als auf dem Mars. Auf dem Mars ist es etwas höher als auf dem Mond. Wir haben es mit dem Radius zu tun, der ist 2400 gegen 1700 vom Mond. Wir haben natürlich eine höhere Masse. Vielleicht habe ich das 0,4-fache der Schwerkraft auf der Erde. Deutlich, aber schwächer als auf der Erde. Das wird eigentlich nicht das Problem sein. Ich denke, die thermischen Belastungen werden das große Problem sein. Die Frage ist natürlich, was macht man da, was interessiert an der Stelle? Das interessiert natürlich, was jetzt Curiosity macht, letztendlich auch eine genaue chemische Kartierung des Materials auf der Oberfläche beobachten. Natürlich sehen wir auf dem Merkur, wissen von dem Merkur noch nicht, von seiner Diversität von morphologischen und geochemischen, mineralogischen Lagen und stellen wir es jetzt vom Maß her kennen. Wir haben ja durch die vielen Instrumente, die wir dort im Umlauf hatten, durch die vielen Kameras, schon ein relativ gutes, vorgeprägtes Bild vom Maß. Wir wissen, dass da eine große Varietät da ist. Das wissen wir von Merkur heute so noch nicht. Insofern können wir nicht sagen, ob wir das gleich erwarten würden und in welche Richtung wir dann ziehen würden. Aber sicherlich würden wir versuchen, auf jeden Fall einen grauen Strust zu machen. Das heißt, auf der Oberfläche die Mineralogie und Chemie der Gestalt zu beobachten, die man ja ansonsten nur aus dem Orbit mit Spektrometern hat beobachten können. Und dann würde man sicherlich versuchen, so typische In-situ-Beobachtungen zu machen, wie beispielsweise eine Bestimmung des Wärmeflusses. Man würde möglicherweise auch einen Seismometer mit an Bord haben, mit dem man dann gucken kann, ob der Merkur in irgendeiner Form innen drin aktiv ist und tatsächlich Seismische Wellen auslöst, seien es auch nur thermische Cracks, die auch durch die thermische Belastung entstehen. Man wird die also in gewisser Weise auswerten können. Sollte es stärkere Beben haben, könnte man daraus einiges lernen. Man wird versuchen, denke ich mal, in situ magnetische Eigenschaften zu vermessen für die Magnetosphärenleute und die sich mit der Wechselwirkung des Magnetfelds mit dem Planeten und dem Sonnenbind interessieren, wäre also ein Punkt auf der Oberfläche und beobachten direkt auf der Oberfläche noch von sicherlich großem Interesse. Also da gibt es eine Reihe von Fragestellungen, die letztendlich so eine Mission motivieren würde. Man müsste dann mal sehen, wie dieser Vorschlag dann in der Konkurrenz mit anderen Vorschlägen, die die Gemeinde der Astronomen und Planetenforschern hervorbringt, dann sich schlagen würde und ob sie konkurrenzfähig wäre. Das wäre jetzt im Augenblick ein bisschen schwer zu sagen. Aber ich würde halt sagen, lassen Sie uns mal abwarten, was bei BepiColombo rauskommt. Dann wird man wahrscheinlich diesen nächsten Schritt diskutieren.
Der dann natürlich entsprechend noch weit in der Zukunft liegt.
So ist es. Aber da kommen wir zurück auf das, was ich vorhin sagte, als Planetenforscher muss man lernen, auch für die nachfolgenden Generationen zu arbeiten. Da darf man nicht zu sehr egoistisch sein.
Man könnte auch sagen, ein Beruf mit Zukunft.
Ein Beruf mit Zukunft.
Das kann durchaus so sein. Das ist dann sicherlich eine Nische. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist ein sehr interessanter Beruf. Und ja, das ist auch einer, in dem man halt auch tätig sein kann. Das sieht man ja hier im Hause. Da gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe von Leuten, die Planetenforschung als ihr Ding erkannt haben und es dann auch umsetzen können.
Ja, der Merkur, ein noch recht unbekanntes Wesen, kann man, glaube ich, zusammenfassen. Man ist ihm auf der Spur. Und es ist ein bisschen spannend zu sehen, was man vor allem aus den zu gewinnenden Erkenntnissen noch so schließen kann. Aber ganz offensichtlich scheint er doch schon eine relativ wichtige Rolle zu spielen, beim Aufschlüsseln der Gesamtantwort auf Entstehung mindestens unseres Sonnensystems, wenn nicht sogar auch der von anderen.
Ja, also ich denke, da liegt sicherlich die Motivation für diese und andere Mission, dass man hergeht und verstehen will, wie ist das Sonnensystem entstanden, wie passt das alles zusammen? Die Rosetta-Mission ist auch eine Mission, die erkunden will, wie das Sonnensystem entstanden ist. Wir gucken immer einerseits auf die Körper selbst, die wir dann erforschen wollen, weil sie da sind und verstehen, was ist da. Andererseits stellen sich uns immer die Frage, wo kommen wir her, wo geht es hin, gibt es noch Leben sonst wo und so weiter. Da machen wir eine vergleichende Planetologie. Da sind diese Entstehungsfragen besonders wichtig. Wir werden jetzt nicht den Merkur erfahren im Hinblick auf Habitabilität, also Belebbarkeit, Leben. Das machen wir bei Mars, im äußeren Sonnensystem, bei mir bei der Monde Europa oder sonst wo. Aber er ist für uns im Gesamtbild wichtig, als der Planet, der innerste Planet, ein extremer Planet. Aus dem extremen Land lernt man immer etwas. Was raussticht, das ist interessant. Das muss Gründe geben, wo es raussticht. Dann muss man die Gründe erforschen und lernt was bei.
Super, ich denke, dann können wir jetzt den Sack auch zumachen.
Dann bedanke ich mich.
Ja, ich bedanke mich vor allem. Die Hörer bedanken sich, die auch fleißig zugehört haben. Bei denen bedanken wir uns natürlich auch gleich. Noch nehme ich für das fortwährende Interesse, was hier in unseren Gesprächen entgegengebracht wird. Ja, und das war es. Ausgabe Nummer 44. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald wieder mal bei Raumzeit.